[Music]
[Applause]
Daniel Jeremiah NFL network analyst
Chargers radio analyst and move the Styx
podcast co-host he's got a tough job
because he's in Kansas City he's got his
final final final mock draft and he has
no idea what's going to go on and
neither do we and it hasn't there
haven't been too many drafts where we've
gone in Daniel saying I don't know
what's going to happen I assume we know
what's happening at at the top right
Bryce Young's going to Carolina
I I feel like we know that that might be
the only thing that we know Dan at this
point in time but I mean as an analyst
for this thing you wrote for two things
you were for quarterbacks and chaos and
I think we're going to be two for two in
this one okay but there's no official
report that Bryce young is going to
Carolina
no
can you remember the last time where we
didn't know the number one overall pick
I I go back to the Kyler Murray Year we
We were pretty certain but it wasn't
nailed down and then when they we were
on set as the red carpet show was taking
place so you're just kind of getting
miked up you're just kind of Milling
around and I look over at the Monitor
and I see Kyler Murray in a red and pink
pinstripe suit and I said oh yeah so
that's a that's an Arizona Cardinals
number one overall pick suit that he's
wearing I feel still feel and felt that
the Draft starts at number two
yeah that's that's where it is I mean if
we assume and I think it will happen
Bryce young goes number one
um now if we're 95 sure the number one
pick we are five percent sure of the
number two pick no clue I mean it's it's
normally Dan it's like okay and I think
that like the Trey Lance we had this
conversation that year uh day of the
draft and I said look there's enough
coming late here that I believe Trey
Lance is going to be the pick over Mac
Jones for San Francisco like that was
kind of the last little riddle and you
felt maybe 80 confident like nothing's
got out of Houston I mean there's all
this noise and all this uproar about you
know well there won't they with CJ
Stroud but no concrete information what
do you think they should do
I think they should take CJ Stroud
um so to me I think there's there's no
way you can come out of these first two
picks without your quarterback
um I don't think they're future
quarterbacks on their roster and I don't
buy into the theory of well you know
what next year there's great
quarterbacks well yeah there's no
guarantee you're going to be picking up
here next year you've got a chance to to
draft a guy who's better than anybody
that you have which I think CJ Stroud is
yeah um so go ahead and take him now Dan
there's only every couple years where
you're going to have a guy like Trevor
Lawrence where you're going to sleep
great at night no one okay I feel this
is a high this is a high high likelihood
this guy is going to be a stud those
guys don't come around very often you
gotta you gotta take a little bit of a
leap here but you got to go for it
so you got drama two and then you throw
in Arizona you know do they go with
Paris Johnson do they get their you know
left tackle or do they trade out of that
because somebody wants to trade up to
get a quarterback what do you think
happens
well there's so many holes there and
they've made it known they're screaming
from the mountaintops they would love to
get out of there
um so you know the challenge is I did it
for to have some fun in a mock draft and
I thought okay if Houston's really down
to Will Anderson and uh CJ Stroud I can
fudge it and then just make a trade and
give them both so uh I I took that out
of the out of the mix Arizona gets the
trade down they covet they go down to 12
and they could still get you know one of
the top offensive linemen but having
said that when you dig into it and look
at draft day trades over the last few
years five or six years then there
hasn't been a draft day trade to move up
into like the top five the last one was
trubisky and that was one spot like we
haven't seen a team go from 10 11 12 and
come all the way up to three you got to
go back to I think it's 2014 uh when
that happened so the trades have been
happening at 10. you saw Fields move up
to take fields at 10. we've seen other
movement in that range but as of late
you know when you're going to make a a
jump into the top three usually that
takes place ahead of time
quarterback who could be a bust
well I think you can flip a coin on
Richardson and Levis
um you know I feel like there's dividing
lines here Bryce young to me is the best
one there's a little bit of a gap then
you get to Stroud but I think you know I
think both those guys are Rock Solid
then I think you start you know it's a
little bit of a wild card now uh I have
Richardson next for me because the
upside is ridiculous but the sample size
scares the heck out of me you know it's
a Trail of Tears when you look at the
guys with that limited of a sample size
and then when you look at will Levis
it's just uh you know it's a roller
coaster ride when you when you pop on
the tape and you know I I get a little
bit nervous when you know through the
process you go yeah but you know the
injuries but then the offensive line the
flame there's a lot of butts yeah uh
that makes me a little nervous yeah I
got to see consistency if you can't be
consistent in college you're not going
to be consistent and your accuracy
doesn't change it's usually who you are
and now we're saying oh you know
somebody's going to change will Levis
they'll make him more accurate it's rare
I think when that happens maybe
technique maybe you know throwing motion
your footwork but it feels like what you
are in college accuracy wise is what
you'll be in the pros if not worse yeah
and people point to Josh Allen here
because he made such a leap with
accuracy yeah but I go back first of all
he's at Wyoming this is apples and
oranges comparing who he's with uh who
he's playing with there the other thing
is with Josh I could pull out throws of
him you know throwing with touch like
layered balls he wasn't consistent but
I've seen him do it it'd be like
watching a golfer and I've seen you can
hit these shots you're just not doing it
consistently with Levis it's just
everything is firm that there's just
there's not a lot of touch to his
football so that to me is more difficult
to change we're talking to Daniel
Jeremiah NFL network analyst he'll be on
the call NFL Network providing live
coverage to the draft starting tonight
at 8 Eastern now that you have Aaron
Rodgers what did the Jets do with their
15th overall pick
I mean the defense is in pretty good
shape and having Rogers there it just
feels like this will be a Rogers
influence selection
um so I I just keep going back to that
offensive line and if skaronsky gets
there from Northwestern he's similar to
Vera Tucker in that Vera Tucker is a
guard but can play tackle he played some
tackle at USC skaronsky's a tackle who
something could play guard uh Dan I I've
you know I saw it last year with the
charges with a guy like Jamari Sawyer
who was you know a six-round pick but he
had some flexibility and versatility
over a 17-game season having offensive
lineman that can go inside and outside
and always allow you to get your five
best guys on the field is huge so as
much as I love the talent of Makai
becton he hasn't been reliable and
healthy
um I think to me that's a that's a good
way for them to go where should be Jean
Robinson go
well he's my third overall player uh in
a draft with so many exceptions and
little you know little guys and
inexperienced players like I feel like
he comes in clear packaging you know you
know exactly what you're getting with
him I think he's gonna be a great player
he's gonna be a top five running back in
the league
um I I always say with running backs I
think it makes more sense if you're a
finished product to kind of put that
finishing piece in there
um and I look at the Philadelphia Eagles
and I say okay well what are the premier
positions they've got the quarterback
yeah but you worked for the Eagles
though Daniel and you know I'm getting
there they're not gonna they're not
gonna take I know but I don't get it I
want it I want it so bad I want it so
bad and then so I I've been telling
people they say where'd she go so he
should go to Philadelphia and I list out
all this list of reasons and I go but I
worked with Howie for two years and he's
not gonna do it so I'm I'm selfishly
hoping Dan just for you because you know
this now I'm hoping that they do shock
the world and take him just so that my I
won by one person watching here and Dan
Patrick can see my live reaction on the
air and just see me turn flush white
that he actually that he actually did it
I I love Bijan Robinson and I and I
think that personality is wonderful
um the the position obviously is flawed
financially yeah but if I know I can get
a Difference Maker
like what would stop the Jets from
taking Bichon Robinson he helped you
immediately
yeah I think with Breece Hall what we
saw from him last year I think he can do
a lot of those things you know I think
they're actually pretty similar players
but I would put it this way this would
be my sales pitch in the draft room so
let's go back uh to 2012 I'll jump into
the Philly draft room and I would make
this case
um let's let's Rebrand it let's not talk
about running backs let's look at this
as an ow we're going to call him an
offensive weapon and if you look at the
team that is our Nemesis or our
competition in conference it is us and
the 49ers they have McCaffrey they have
Debo we we could have our own version of
that here with Bijan Robinson and if if
Debo Samuel is a a major and wide
receiver who Miners and running back
we're going to have a Bijan Robinson who
majors in running back and minors as a
wide receiver yeah I agree I I when we
had him on I said I see as a Debo Samuel
kind of weapon here and yes and that's
the way I would use him he's got
wonderful hands and you're you know it
just feels like he's got star power
so I think we could get together on this
thing and we're kind of forming a
running back Union we're rebranding
we're calling them offensive weapons not
everybody's going to fall into that
you're going to have still have your
three yard and a cloud of dust type
backs but for guys like Bijan Robinson
let's let's put him in a different
category if Hendon hooker was 22 22.
finish that sentence I think I think
he'd be a lock as a first round pick I
don't think even you know I think he's
got a good opportunity to go in the
first round as uh you know somebody
who's older but to me
um it's not as big of an issue as it
used to be because if you look at the
quarterbacks that have flopped recently
now as I mentioned with the number of
starts like it's the inexperienced
younger guys who are getting thrown out
of the field and aren't ready for it and
if you look at the value picks in the
draft look at the starting quarterbacks
that were taken outside the first round
when you look at you know the Kirk
Cousins the Dak Prescott we saw it last
year with rock Purdy those guys played a
ton of ball a little bit older arrived a
little bit more mature a little bit more
experienced so I don't think that's
frowned upon quite as much as it would
have been a few years back wildest rumor
you've heard
oh gosh uh last night I heard a rumor
that the uh Titans were gonna trade up
to eight to secure Anthony Richardson to
try and keep anybody else from moving up
to get him and then Ryan Tannehill was
going to get traded to the Arizona
Cardinals so that was a rumor that was
floating around last night I don't know
what you do with it whoa yeah sometimes
you don't want to hear those
like when I covered the NBA draft and
you would hear these rumors and then I
didn't want to cloud my head with the
possibility of something like that
because just like you said I don't know
what I do with this I don't know yeah
but if you I mean that's the that's the
beauty of being in this spot right like
like Ian Ian Rapport you know he's got
to vet that type of stuff I'm like wow
I've heard a million stories that's just
the latest one that I've heard uh it's
been quiet on the Lamar Jackson front
I think that the waters have calmed
there now that's kind of the vibe that I
get
um I think the I think the Odell Beckham
move was a little bit of an olive branch
to him
um saying okay hey we're gonna we've got
a new offensive coordinator
um it's gonna play a little bit more to
you as a passer than maybe the previous
offense that's one Olive Branch now we
bring in Odell Beckham okay can't say
we're not investing in weapons and
receivers
um so I don't know if they're able to
come together on a long-term deal but it
doesn't feel like there's uh this
Collision Course that maybe we were
headed on a month ago and then DeAndre
Hopkins I don't know if he's going to
Buffalo if he's going to go to Baltimore
uh any thoughts on you know Arizona is
ready to unload him but who's going to
take that contract
yeah I mean that's there's two sides of
that I think you hit it I mean I think
Arizona would be happy to move on and
and continue to uh kind of take this
thing down to the studs but uh I I don't
know who's gonna you know who's gonna be
in on that Buffalo is a team that you
hear rumored I know there's you know
there's some talk with Buffalo with wide
receivers in this draft and maybe Diggs
can spend some more time in the slot so
you know looking at some outside
receivers in the draft and if you know
if you're gonna move let digs play a
little bit in the slot then having
Hopkins on the outside would be a pretty
pretty fun combination provided he's
healthy and the player that we you know
we remember him being let me go back to
the Titans you mentioned that the wild
rumor maybe they go up and get Anthony
Richardson have they moved on from Malik
Willis
I don't get that I don't get that sense
that they've completely moved on but I
don't think there's you know I don't
think the the faith and trust has been
put in him that okay we have our future
quarterback going forward I I think
there's a balance saying we haven't
given up on someone
um
Daniel very much so you can't go yeah we
saw enough after one year we're moving
on from him
yeah I would say they're dating I would
not say they would refer to themselves
in a committed relationship
foreign
have fun tonight
I appreciate you buddy I've got to make
sure you got my new phone number Dan
because I always appreciate your text
during this thing you know what fritzy
if you you have a new phone number
contact for Daniel now during the
commercial breaks I'll text you yeah not
when you're on here because that's
unprofessional
no well I would never check there and
while we're on there come on Dan you
know you've taught me better than that
you've been on the set where guys are
checking their phones
I've been on the set when guys are
checking their phones as the camera
[Laughter]
I'll try to uh only uh annoy you during
the commercial breaks you're the best
buddy thanks man that's Daniel Jeremiah
NFL network analyst and providing live
coverage draft tonight Kansas City
starting at 8 Eastern